it's been over 20 years since audience
has followed effervescent Sorority Girl
L Woods to Harvard Law School in the
bubblegum comedy Legally Blonde she
continued to ascend the professional
ladder in 2003's Legally Blonde 2 red
white and blonde which saw L head to
Washington DC now L is back in addition
to starring as L Reese Witherspoon will
also act as a producer this time through
her hello sunshine banner and she's
brought on never have I ever Creator
Mindy Kaling and Brooklyn 99's Dan Gore
to pen the screenplay also returning for
the sequel is Jennifer kulage who
starred in both previous films as El's
friend pette a character who kaing
teased will have a really juicy role in
the film as for the rest of the original
cast we're still not sure who will be
returning but we do know that there will
be a lot of new faces in legely blond 3
along with a lot more diversity